Скажи, будь ласка, що ти думаєш про наголос у слові "спина"? - Спина.
До свого учителя Артура Пройдакова учні звертаються без "по-батькові" - просто Артур.
Він викладає українську мову й літературу в одній з приватних столичних шкіл.
Найперше - вчить дітей любити мову.
Насправді він дуже класний вчитель, і ми всі це розуміємо.
Я полюбила українську мову, тому що я її ненавидила, не розуміла ці правила.
Але так, Артуру дійсно вдалося це зробити, бо він сам її любить.
На уроках у Артура учні слухають український реп, дивляться відео з TikTok,
шукають помилки в піснях, мемах і публічних промовах. Торік Артур Пройдаков
став найкращим учителем року за версією Global Teacher Prize.
Я не розмовляю українською мовою повсякденно, але... він дуже гарно розповідає.
Взагалі з Артуром є такий класний момент: навіть якщо ти не йдеш на його уроки,
ну всі ходять, але якщо ти захворів чи ще шось, він тебе оточить українською мовою всюди.
У нього є подкасти, в нього є Телеграм-канал. І якщо в тебе є інтерес до цього,
а він робить усе дуже цікаво, але якщо в тебе є інтерес до цього,
то в тебе є можливість вивчати українську мову завжди й усюди.
Завдяки таким, як Артур, дітей російськомовних родин успішно
навчають говорити українською. А як щодо їхніх батьків та решти киян?
Зважаючи на те, що вже рік як уся сфера послуг мала перейти на українську.
У січні торік набула чинності відповідна стаття закону про мову.
То чи є результат? Ідемо перевіряти!
О, це російською - "Кофелечебница", і це вже можна говорити про порушення.
Еспресо, латте з двома "т" - це російською.
У самісінькому центрі столиці - порушення закону. Уже рік, як уся інформація
про товари й послуги має надаватися українською.
Українська, російська, російська. Ось тут взагалі помилка - буква "т" непотрібна,
відбувається спрощення, слово "захисних" без букви "т".
У цій крамниці нас вітають російською, хоча продавець одразу переходить на українську.
Принаймні, намагається.
Добрий день. - Здравствуйте. - Що думаєте з приводу закону про мову,
який зобов'язує сферу послуг перейти на українську? - Ну, не знаю… Кому як… удобно.
Артур "двійку" за таке спілкування ставити не поспішає. Зізнається:
сам довго залишався російськомовним. Він родом зі Стаханова
- нині Кадіївка Луганської області, на окупованій території.
У Стаханові я перемикався постійно. Урок закончился, звонок прозвенел,
я перехожу на русский язык. А зараз я розумію, що це неправильна позиція.
Якщо я знаю українську, якщо це моя професія, то мені простіше
говорити українською в будь-якій сфері, де б я не перебував.
Поки ж робимо перерву. І тут нас зігрівають не лише чай з кавою,
а й українська від продавців - ще й зі знанням закону.
Взагалі, за правилами, потрібно починати з гостями розмовляти українською,
а далі вже якщо гість сам розмовляє російською або, наприклад,
англійською, то можна переходити на мову, якою він розмовляє.
У нас для вас є приз за найдетальніше пояснення закону про мову.
Артуре! - Корисні подарунки! - Дякуємо!
Натомість у найближчому торговому центрі все не так райдужно.
Нас зустрічає промовиста вивіска російською.
Перепрошую, а у вас називається магазин "Очи черные".
А законом про українську мову з попереднього року всі заклади, вивіски
мають бути українською мовою. Ви не знаєте, чому у вас така назва залишається ще?
- Ні… - Це адміністрація розпоряджається інформацією? - Мабуть, якось да…
А ж ось наше спілкування швидко переходить в інше русло.
Я перепрошую, у нас відео і фотозйомка заборонена!
Починаються скандали, треба тікати…
Вирвалися. Але поруч помічаємо ще один вказівник російською,
цікавимося інформацією у продавчині.
А ви продавчиня і в тому відділі? - Нет, тот отдел - следующий магазин. Под стеклом, да?
Нагадаємо, за законом, говорити з покупцями потрібно українською.
Цікавимося думкою жінки щодо такої норми.
Свобода воли - есть у нас такое? - Закон у нас є про мову. - Ну закон...
Ви знаєте, шо у нас нема державної печатки?
Схоже, назріває ще один скандал, а хотілося б хоч дрібку позитиву.
І ми її отримуємо від ось цієї продавчині.
Батько росіянин, мама росіянка, батько військовий.
У 1991 році Україна стала державою, не республікою, і мову повинні знати всі! Я її вивчила!
Результати нашої мовної інспекції неоднозначні. Українську дійсно нині чути частіше,
утім і порушення залишаються.
Я думаю, що ми на правильному шляху. Я думаю, що позитивні тенденції є,
і з часом картинка наша мовна буде змінюватися на краще.
І щось мені підказує, що якщо далі, п'ять років, десять років буде діяти цей мовний закон
без виправлень, редакцій і так далі, то у нас буде зафіксовано
набагато менше порушень і у вивісках, і в назвах закладів, і у спілкуванні продавців,
сфери обслуговування і з клієнтами, і з покупцями.
Те, що порушення є, визнають і в офісі уповноваженого із захисту державної мови.
До відомства за рік надійшло більше трьох з половиною тисяч скарг.
Найбільше порушень - у Києві й області. Далі - Харків, Одеса, Дніпро.
Найчастіше громадяни помічали, що інтернет-магазини ведуть сторінки
не державною мовою. Також порушення фіксували у сфері обслуговування й реклами.
На нашу адресу надходить звернення, і якщо воно справді містить усю необхідну інформацію,
я як уповноважений протягом десяти днів ухвалюю відповідне рішення про подальші дії.
Якщо справді ситуація надзвичайно критична, то ми можемо
розпочати заходи державного контролю. Ми можемо надіслати
на адресу порушника листа з інформацією-роз'ясненням.
Якщо справді ми проводимо заходи державного контролю, складаємо акт
і вимагаємо усунути порушення.
Уповноважений називає свою роботу "лагідною українізацією".
Тому й жодного штрафу поки нікому не виписали - усі суперечності
вдалося владнати мирно. У 2022 році набудуть чинності нові норми закону про мову.
З 16 січня усі друковані ЗМІ повинні будуть мати українську версію.
А з 16 липня штрафувати за порушення закону про мову можна буде
не лише установу чи заклад, а й конкретних осіб - приміром, офіціантів, продавців чи чиновників.
В офісі уповноваженого прогнозують, що роботи в них стане більше.
Тож планують розширюватися й хочуть розмістити своїх представників у кожній області.
Але, як запевняє уповноважений, скандалів прагнуть якнайменше.
На жаль, в Україні мовне питання все ще залишається політичним,
і кожна хвиля імплементації мовного законодавства, заяви уповноваженого
або мовні скандали, які трапляються як з порушниками, так і з тими,
хто захищають мовний закон, стають суспільно резонансними.
Так звичайно довго бути не повинно. Ми за те, щоб закон імплементувався,
порушень ставало якомога менше, можливо, колись і настане той абсолют,
коли не буде порушень, і потреба в уповноваженому із захисту державної мови відпаде.
У Артура Пройдакова свій рецепт "лагідної українізації" - через навчання й культуру.
Як успішний приклад - наводить своїх учнів.
Я бачу в молоді невороже ставлення до української мови. Це раз.
Якщо раніше це сприймалося як агресивне насаджування, зараз українська мова
- це значна частина лайфстайлу, життєвого стилю молоді.
Ми досліджуємо публічні промови відомих особистостей, певні помилки
в їхніх усних виступах тощо. І, звичайно, намагаємося пізнавати
українську музику, культуру. Наприклад, беремо тексти сучасних українських пісень
і працюємо з цими текстами, досліджуємо там члени речення,
синтаксичну будову речення або словосполучень. Моя фішка в тому,
що ми ненав'язливо знайомимося із сучасною українською культурою.
Це дуже важливо показати дітям, що є важливий пласт самобутньої культури.
Можливо, вони і не послухали б цієї пісні, не подивилися б відео.
Але є уроки української в школі, то чому б це не зробити на уроках в школі?
Аби його рецепт подіяв, каже Артур, потрібен час.
І в будь-якому разі - поменше мовних скандалів.